did you know that this injury afflicts
women up to eight times more than men at
least two million people tear an ATL in
one of their knees every year and it's
becoming increasingly common tens of
players are missing the 2023 women's
football World Cup because of it an ACL
tear is usually a consequence of awkward
movement in a fast-paced game the injury
is excruciating and immobilizing it
normally requires surgery and can take
up to a year to recover from but why do
women suffer the injury more often than
men evidence suggests it may be linked
to the menstrual cycle a four-year study
of 100 Female England footballers found
that muscle and tendon injuries were far
more common in the late follicular phase
when estrogen levels Spike just prior to
ovulation compared with men women also
have wider hips more inverted knees and
less muscle mass but by training
athletes to move more safely and by
encouraging coaches to speak more openly
about women's health this devastating
injury could become more preventable